はい では 始まります 題唱
失敗の意味 失敗って何ですか？期待する結果に比較するならば
失敗という観念が生じるんですね
だから機会期待する結果という概念があると失敗というんです
それはない場合は別の人生
失敗とは言えませんよ
失敗した時の悩み 苦しみ
落ち込みは 結果に対する欲望
願望の強弱に対称しています
だから失敗 失敗と軽々く言うんだけど
失敗 失敗と言った途端もう何か期待
期待 期待 期待 願望っていうのはあるんですよ
そこからの心理 崩れています
そういうものは本当はないんだからね
すべて変わっていくんだからね
それで それから我々 失敗した時はすごく落ち込んだりするでしょうね
どれぐらい落ち込むかというと
どれぐらい期待やったかということによります
それほど期待しなかったならばね
失敗しても ああそうかということで終わっちゃいます
誰でもしたくはないが
誰でもやってしまうことは失敗なんです
失敗のそれも特色なんで
誰もやりたくはない しかし
みんなやってるんです
失敗の推移者ということで
まあ仲間ですね 家来ですね
だから失敗は大丈夫ですけど
この家来はね 推随者ってもの
まあ自称にはあるのは推随だけですけど
失敗には応援する仲間が多いんです
仲間は応援するんだから
ますます失敗するんです
ですから 一度の失敗が人は鈍足に陥って自己破壊になるまで悪化するんです
人は一度失敗したら これから次から次へと失敗に繋がって転げていくんですよ
この応援の問題なんですね
周りが気楽に失敗を批判する
この周りの人々はすごい気楽に人の失敗を批判するんです
なんか自分が失敗したことはなかったように
失敗者の心の傷はさらに深くなるんですよ
それでまあ 失敗した時点でもとっくに心に傷ついてるのに
周りはそこはまたもう批判するんだから
これはもうみんなやりますけど
そこはもう合わないんです
人の失敗を喜ぶ者もいる
それでは今日書いてないんだけど
人の失敗を喜んじゃう人もいますよ
その喜ぶ人は批判しません
喜んでいるんだから まあいいんじゃないか
それぐらいは とかね それは今の失敗って言っちゃらもう無視しなさいとかね
あれ なんとか一見いいように見えますけど
それでその人には自分開き直っちゃって
また自分を直そうということはなくなっちゃうんです
狙いはもうとことんやれということなんです
だから批判する人々はとことんやってほしくないんです
失敗は だから批判するんですよ
でも批判されると 自分の傷がさらにさらに大きくなっちゃって
がんぐらい大きくなっちゃって
もう自己破壊のところまで行ってしまうんですよ
だからどちらの道でも正しくないんです
世の他人の批判から 場合によって逃げることも無視することもできるが
まあ他人の批判 世の批判というのはね
まあ無視することも そこから逃げることもね
できますよ 失敗したところで逃げちゃったと
場合によって誰か人 子供を車で撥ねてね
逃げていたんですけど
でも捕まったんですからね
いつでもできるわけじゃないんですけど
内面的な推進者たちにたちは最大の危険です
自分の心の中での応援するところがね
逃げませんね 内面のところ
内のところ 相手がガチャガチャ言う中で黙っていなさいとか言うこともできますよ
うるさいと 当たり前のことを言うなよと
結構こちらで気に気になってますよと言っておくと
なんとかそこを抑えられますよ
世間も でも自分の心の問題をどうやって教えますかと
自分と一緒だからね 失敗者の悩み
落ち込み 怒り 後悔などから逃げられません
一体になってしまうんです
だから危険なのはそれなんですね
この怒りにより 能力と心の動きがさらに硬くなったり弱くなったりする
これでちょこっと説明しなくちゃいけない
我々 何か失敗したら落ち込んだりするでしょうね
それ怒りなんです 悩んだりするでしょ
怒りなんです 後悔するでしょ
それも怒りなんです だから
失敗した時の心理学とか
そんなにたくさん要りません
失敗した人の気持ちは何なのかと
たった １個怒っているんです
その怒りは微妙に質が違うんです
例えば人に怒ることっていうのはすごいシンプルなんです
人が邪魔をしたと怒った
すごいシンプルなものなんです
それが 解決できません
なぜならば 怒った理由がありますね
邪魔したと それから怒った対象があるんですね
この人に怒っていると
この人のところにもう一人いたら
その人には怒ってないんです
二人で来て一人が邪魔したら
その人に怒っているんだから
この怒りがコンパクトで単純でわかりやすい
なのに世間はそれがすごい大きな問題にしているんです
失敗した人は何に怒っているんですかね
それから対象は誰ですかね
定めてないんです 定めてない
いわゆるターゲットをね
定めてなく鉄砲を撃っているんだから
何人死ぬかわからないんですよ
まあ例えばある人を殺したいと狙って
その人に狙って あの この
何ですか そういう人を見てますね
ものすごいもう上手なね
で 狙って撃つ場合は 周りに人いたっても大丈夫なんですよ
鉄砲を撃つ人がすごいプロだからね
周りに全然気づかないように遠いところからピシッと撃つんです
それが危険じゃないんです
死ぬのは一人ですから
中学生が機関銃を持って撃ちまくっちゃうと
誰が死ぬんですかね？何人死ぬんですかね
決まってないんです だから怒りの場合は
このターゲットを定めてない怒りこそすごい危険なんです
それで この失敗した人の怒りはターゲットはないんですね
自分に怒っているんでしょうか
仕事に失敗したことに怒っているんでしょうか
仕事を頼んだ人に怒っているんでしょうか
そう わからないんです
だから失敗した場合は周りにまで怒るんですよ
周りは関係ないのに そこは本人が
まあ私は落ち込んでいる
悩んでいるというだけで
そんな単純じゃないんです
落ち込み 悩みっていうのは怒りです
これはターゲットを定めてないんです
だから自分 鉄砲は自分の口に入れることもあるし
周りに向けて撃ちまくる場合もあるし
だから失敗っていうのは大変なことなんで
失敗の推移者たちはね
その中でも自分の心から出てくる落ち込みはすごく危ないんです
後悔することは失敗しましたとかね
すごく危ない現象なんで
だから仏教は後悔はとても大きな罪であって
落ち込みもすごい罪なんです
引きこもりも そういうのは単純じゃない
すっごい罪なんです そこで怒りですとわかってないんだから
例えば落ち引っ込んでる引きこもりの人っていうのは
みんな頑張っているんだけど
直すことはできないんですよ
だから怒りで治療すれば治りますよ
若い子たちがそういう問題を抱えてきたら
私は随分早く直しちゃいますけど
あの これライセンス持ってるプロたちやってることは一つもやりません
怒りに対する薬は何ですかね？笑うことでしょうね
笑わせちゃうんですよ
まあ子供だったらね いくら １８と 20歳といってもね
まあ子供だから 小さい時からもう親は可愛がってあげてないんですよ
だからもう自分も可愛いと
大人に言ってほしいんです
で 親の仕事ですけどね
こういう精神的な問題がある子供を見ただけで
まあ両親にも愛されてないとすぐわかるんですよ
欲あるケースの両親ってのは
あまり厳密的で ものすごい理想高くて
一番最悪の場合はインテリで
子供にとっては地獄なんですね
子供に必要なのは愛情だけ
独立した人間だから 自分で成長する
もうちょっと可愛がってくれと
だから親に可愛がってもらったり
からかわれたり いろいろ冗談を言ってもう馬鹿にされたりとか
そういうことをされて楽しけると
まあ自分がすごく親に愛されていて
すごく気楽になるんですね
で 大胆なことをしない
私のやり方っていうのは
もうもうちょっとなんとかしてもう楽しませるんですよ
なんか冗談を言ってからかったり
なんとかするんです それでもうびっしりと自分で頑張って自分の問題を解決するんです
だから それほど難しくないんですけど
だから失敗した時はもう一番問題が
もう自殺するところまで行くのはこの落ち込みのせいなんですけど
で 社会の批判でもね まあ非論理的に受けちゃうと
もうまた自殺する人もいるし
社会の批判なんかまあまあ無視しちゃってもできますけど
無視することもできますけど
何と言われたても気にしないというよね
できるんだけど 自分の心が攻撃することからは無視する
それはできませんね それで処理方法
まず管理者の辺 これ 2つに分けたんですよ
で 管理者っていうのは
この  失敗という言葉から言ったのであって
例えば人が仕事を失敗したならば
仕事を与えた人もいるんだからね
だから私は人に仕事を頼むと
その人は失敗しないで仕事をこなしてもらうように私は気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
何にも気にしないで あんたこれやってくださいと言ったっても
本人にそれできない場合は
失敗するっていうのは当たり前でしょうね
だから管理者の立場での人々は
例えば親は子供の管理者でしょうし
上司は部下の管理者でしょうし
で そうやっても世界では管理者がいるんだから
そういう人々は仕事を与えて
そこで失敗したっていうことは出てくるんだからね
相手の失敗はどのようにすれば直せるのかと研究する必要があるんですよ
管理者はもうそういう人のことは研究しなくちゃいけないんですよ
会社の社長であろうが
どんなところでも学校の校長であろうか
このそこを勉強しないと
人間の性格をね 人間はどうすれば明るくて元気で
自分の仕事を真面目にやるのかと
どうしてあげれば能率は高くなるのかという研究は
管理者になる人々の仕事なんです
１ 失敗があっても 何か良いところを早く見つけて
まずそれを褒める まあいくつか具体的なことを書いましたけど
私は普段は書きませんよ
具体的なことは もうなぜならば
具体的なことっていうのは一般的にならないんだからね
そのケースだけに通じるんだから
例えば誰かが失敗したところで
いきなり怒鳴るんじゃなくて
管理者がなんであんたはこんなことをしたんでしょうか？と
その人はもうわざわざ失敗したわけじゃないんだから
失敗したくてやったわけじゃないんだから
失敗したい人っていうのはいませんだから
世の中で それをわからないと管理者じゃないんです
この人は失敗したくて失敗したんじゃないんです
だから その人に何かいいところ
何かあるんですよ それすぐ見つけて
ああ あんたよく頑張りました
ご苦労様  1週間もかかったの？仕事に
よくめげずに頑張ったんですね
とかね まずそれを褒めるんですよ
失敗に怒鳴るんじゃなくて
だから 相手が部下が失敗した時に限って
まず褒めなくちゃいけないんです
失敗に あ また漢字が間違ってます
失敗に怒るのではなく
褒めた後 今度頑張りましょうと応援するんですよ
ここで管理者が応援者だったら
もう次は失敗しないでしょう
管理者が怒る役だったら
もう会社は失敗します
全体的に だから会社社長
学校の校長 先生とかね
みんな応援者にならなくちゃいけないんです
失敗がしてもしても自分の部下だから
自分の生徒たちだからね
もう宿題はやったんですけど
間違いいっぱいあったら
君 よく宿題はね よくやりますと全部
すごく偉いと 先生楽しいと
怠けないでよく全部やってるんだから
で 今度は 11 間違いありますけど
まあ今回はね 今度は間違いの数を減らすようにと気を付けてできるでしょと言えば子どもは楽しいんですよ
次の宿題は 11 ではなくて
10とかね 8ぐらいにしましょうとかね
そうすると まあやっぱり管理者が味方になってるんだっていうことになってきて
すごく よくなって まあ宿題はやるだけじゃなくて
今度は間違わないようにやるぞというふうに相手が決めるんです
どうしても怒るなら同時に冗談も言う
だから怒って怒鳴る場合でも
怒鳴りながらいろいろ冗談を言った方がいいんです
なんとかふざけてなんとか言った方がいいんです
例えばすごい怒ったところで
お前に怒ったんだからね
私はもう血圧が高くなったんだから
お金払えと 薬買いますから
それからと言ると あの怒られた側が何のこともなく
嫌な気持ちはなくなっちゃうんです
罰金取るも箱でも置いておこうかなとかね
で そうすると あ まあこの上司はもう腹が立っているわけじゃなくて仲間だよということになるんです
仕事を頼んだのは自分だから
失敗に対して十分 あ これ自分ですね
十分に 自分の責任もあるんですね
自分の責任のところも相手に言ってあげる
なんで失敗したんじゃなくて
自分が仕事を与えたんだから
そこは自分の失敗もありますね
まあ具体的に言えば もう君に仕事量多かったねとかね
私はちょこっと仕事量多かったね
これ私の失敗ですよと
それを減らしたならば
ここまではならなかったでしょうねとか言うと
お互い様ですよね それですごく気持ちよくなるんですよ
あんた仕事ですよ 与えた仕事やるのはあんたの仕事ではないかと言って
それはもう管理者のやり方じゃないです
あるいは相手に任せたんだけど
相手にその能力ないこと
能力ない 人の能力はバラバラだからね
それ知らなかったら これ上司のファシストでしょうね
その場合はね そんな気にしなくていいよと
君にはこの能力はなかったことを
君は他のことはできるんですけど
これはできないと 私はちょっと気づかなかったんだと
これは上司として私の失敗やと
というと その時点でお互い仲良くなってますよ
例えば 私の説明が足らなかった
あなたに与えた責任は少々大きかった
赤字の問題で私もイライラしていたとか
なんとか言って 自分の責任もちゃんと失敗した人に言う
5.楽しい明るい環境を作ること
とにかく上司の仕事ですよ
社長の仕事なんですよ
学校だったら学長やら校長やら
そういう人々の仕事なんです
もう雰囲気を明るく 楽しく
我が家のような感じに作ってあげる
仕事上 上司であっても
私的には友人に仲間にしてあげること
人間平等ですよ だから固定した上下関係ないんです
仕事上は上下があります
学校にもあります 生徒たちはもう先生たち言うことを聞かなくちゃいけないし
家庭に入ったら親が言うことを聞かなくちゃいけないし
そういうものは固定している
変わらないものじゃないんで
だから仕事で上司は上司でいいんだけど
個人的に相手が仲間で友達だと
しなきゃダメなんですよ
人にその人の仕事の手ごまあ
もう 1度言いますけど
あの その人の家のこともどうでしょうかとかね
子供はどうでしょうか
元気でしょうかとかね
会社の仕事終わってから
もうすごく仲間で友達のように
もう課長 課長と呼ぶなよと
ちゃんと私に名前があるでしょうと
会社から出たらもう課長も誰もいないんだよと
いうふうにした方がいいでしょうに
人にその人の仕事の手応え
手応え 手応えを感じさせること
充実感を与えるということですね
一人一人に手応えを与える
感じさせないとね 自分がこれぐらいやりましたと
なかなかもう仕事をしているんだというね
充実感与えるように工夫しなくちゃいけない
...大仕事を小さなセクションに分解してやったけど
いきなり大仕事を任せるんじゃなくて
これ管理者が仕事はちゃんと段取りを踏んで
小さな小さなセクションに切って切って切って切って切って切って与えた方がいいんです
それで仕事する側はセクション
セクション セクション完了するんですよ
それで手応えもあるし
充実感もあるんです いっぺん大仕事与えちゃうと
これ手応えを感じないんですよ
その人の管轄の中で自分で判断して必要な結果を出すようにと自由と責任を与える
うん これ与えるです そこで大きな仕事は小さいセクションに分解したら
何人かの人々が仕事するでしょ
一人じゃないんだから
そこで大仕事をもう細かく細かく細かく
このあれ 何でしたっけ？ジグソーパズルのようにもうバラバラにする
それで一人一人 一人一人にセクション
セクションを与える それでその自分のセクションは自分のもので
自分の管轄で自分が判断してやるというね
その自由を与えなくちゃいけないんです
で 日本のいろいろこの会社でね
まあ会社 私は行ったことはないんですけど
このたまーになんとかあって
この受付でなんとかなんとか頼まなくちゃありますけど
あの連中にはまあお客さん対応なんですけど
あの決まってるテキスト以上は喋れません
こういう風に質問したらはいという
こういう風にしたらノーという
それ以上何もできないんです
だから何の責任もないんですね
それで外国行ったり チケット買ったりする場合は
もう初めから決まってます
日本の飛行機には乗りませんと
いろいろ変化させたり
いろいろルート変えたり
いろんなこと出ますから
何もできないと それで怒るんだ
あなたが切った買ったのはこちらからこちらでしょう
だけどこれできませんと
だから変えてちょうだいと変えなさいというように言ったら
じゃあ聞いてみますと
そしたら上の人も同じバカだからできません
できません それで私は
じゃああなた方にその余分なお金かかるんだったら
そのお金払いますから
変えてくださいと そしたらじゃあ聞いてみますと
できませんと と言った途端
私の中にもこれはまあ変える方法を知ってますよと言ったら
はい わかりましたと 私はここからここまで行って
ここからルート変えますからねと
見てくださいと言って
そこ外国の人 外国人だって言ってるからね
なんのことか これこういう風にルート変えてくださいと言ったら
向こう向こうはできません
できませんじゃなくてできるでしょ OKOK
これちょっと 2,000円必要ですけど
どうですか？ 2,000円払いますから
なんのことなく 10 分 10 分もかかりません
くださいと まあ怒りますからと
だからすごく強い そういうところは
日本ではすごく厳しいんです
誰にも責任ないんです
全部もう流せるんですよ
だから能率っていうのはもう最悪
そこを直さないために世界一能率高いと自分で自画自賛しているんですよ
結果何であろうと だからすごくきついと思いますよ
日本の社会は 今 ものすごい激しく社会変わっているでしょうに
経済状況もね 中国やら韓国やらもうなかなか
今日の昨日新聞で読んだんですけど
アメリカの誰かさんがね
あの学者がね 日本はもう国際世界でね
リーダーを投入しているのは日本じゃなくて中国は
しかし このインターナショナルリレーションズの場合はものすごく上手で
見事に日本を切って捨てたんだと
国際世界では だからそこにも言ったのは
このもう余計なこと もうなんで靖国神社に参拝する？なんで靖国参拝するのかと言ったら
小泉さんも素晴らしい頭いいんだから行ってはいけないと言うんだから
カッカすると行くんですね
日本のために それで国際世界のリーダーシップから見事に捨てられちゃったという
それが自慢するんだからね
国民の中で 国の中で私もいるんだから
中国を馬鹿にすることすごい自慢げに思ってるんです
国際的に見ると もうあんた方は負けてるでしょうと
負けたってもいいんだけど
これ経済的な問題考えてください
金がなくなっちゃうんですよ
経済学者だから経済は大事ですからね
ということで やっぱりなんでこの無責任でね
小泉さんもなんで自分で責任取らないんですかね
明らかに日本と中国の関係が悪くなったのは小泉さんというある個人のせいでしょう
うまくいっていたでしょうに
だからやっぱりこれは全体的に見える問題で
あの 受付頼みますよと言ったら
そのセクションだけでも自分勝手に判断してやってくださいと
言わないと私も一応パチパダさんにすると
パチパダの 디자인どうしましょうかと電話かけてきて
よこさんに私は怒ったんです
私に聞くなよと これはあなたに任せているんだから
勝手にやってくださいと
好き勝手に どんなデザインにしようか
これはもうあなたに任せることだからね
こちらは気にしませんと
でも慣れてないんですね
誰かがこの色悪い この文字が悪い
この絵はもうあれやこれ言うと
本人また責任なくなっちゃうでしょうね
それでロボットになって
それで最悪でしょうね
結果通してもやらない人にとっては何でも言いますけど
やる人でしょうね その中身がどうかわかるのは
だから私がいい作品出すぞという
これは私の作品だよというね
気分になったらいいものはできたりはするんです
それでいい結果も出るし
やった本人にも手ごたえ
手ごたえを 手ごたえを感じるんです
理屈はそうなんですけど
やってみてもうまくいかないという
かなりこの根深く この能力ないということをね
ちょっと根深すぎなんです
人はプログラムで動くロボットではないと覚えておくんです
人間というのはプログラムで動くロボットじゃなくて人間なんです
だからアナログなんですよ
みんな プログラム作っちゃうと
これはデジタル的で 仕事はもうあなた
1時間ありますからやってくださいと
ぴったし 1時間できるかできないか
本人もわからないんでしょうね
言う人は言って  1時間ちゃんとやると言ったってもね
人間生身の人間だからね
だからやっぱりうまくいかなくなっちゃって
引っかかっちゃって それでコーヒー一つ飲んで
ちょっと背伸びをしてとかね
そこで間でそこ時間経ったら
また何か別なことを誰かと喋ったりして
そこで気持ち変えて また仕事に行けばいいんです
だから １時間仕事をしました
１０時間も仕事をしましたということは意味がないんですよ
気持ちよくこなしたかと
ということが大事でしょう
それだったら もうずっとコーヒー飲みながらおせんべい食べながら仕事しててもいいんですよ
仕事が動くんだったら
仕事中だから全部おせんべい食べるんじゃないって決めちゃうと
生身の人間ですよ ロボットだったら大丈夫ですよ
プログラムを入れて起動すれば
ずっとまたスイッチオフするまで起動はしますけど
これ一番重要っていうのは大事なことで
みんな人間だっていうこと
そこで個人編 相手の批判を堂々と聞く
認める 失敗したとガチャガチャガチャガチャ言われると
堂々と聞いてやるんです
で 認める 認めてあげちゃうと怒らなくなっちゃうんですよ
怒鳴るのはバカバカらしくなるんで
批判されても 失敗は完全に自己責任でない場合は
その分を徹底的に弁解する
まあ時々この会社でよく起こることで
みんな上の人々はあらゆる悪いことを部下に頼んで
バレると部下だけ自殺するか逮捕されるかどちらかなんです
上はもう向こうは勝手にやったことだから知りません
知りませんでしたとかね
すっごく気持ち悪いんです
そういうことで 自分 まあ自分が勝手にやったならば
自分で責任を取るのは当たり前なんですけど
で 向こうに言われてやって悪いことになって
それでガチャ言うと あなたのせいもあるでしょうにと
どんな偉い人でも その場合は弁解しなくちゃいけないんです
ちゃんと責任分担しなくちゃ
それぞれの失敗はした人々はそれぞれに似合ってはいけないんではないかと
帳簿はこういう風にこういう風に変えなさいと言ったのはあんたでしょ
我々で勝手にできんでしょうにと
だからやった悪いやってバレたことで私も悪いし
命令したあなたも悪いしということで
まあだからはっきりと自分の責任と関係ないところまで自分に責任任せをすると
そこはもう攻撃した方がいいんです
一方的に批判される場合は
過ちを認めた上で 失敗しないようにどうすれば良いのかと
その人からアドバイスを求める
時々はこの部下を叱る人々というのは
喋るは喋るは喋るは喋るは喋るは
まあこれぐらいもう上げなくちゃいかんでしょうとかね
もうもっとこれもっともっと仕事しなきゃ
悪いこと言うだけで品物を売るんだったら
1 日これぐらい売らなきゃダメではないかとか
1日 100個売れなくちゃもうもう間に合わないでしょと何とか言ってもね
それはプログラム的な話で
100個売れなくてといっても
買うか買うのは人間であって
買うかどうか分からないし
そういう風にガチャガチャガチャガチャ言うんだったら
では課長 これはね どうすればうまくいくんでしょうかと
課長が与えたノルマノルマはね
達するために もうしっかりしたやり方を教えてくださいと
その通りにやります 私のやり方でやって
こんな結果だから そうなると相手がバカっていうことすぐバレてしまうんです
これは正しい あの 傷つけないように傷つける方法なんです
だって部下に怒ったね
上司に怒っちゃうと危ないでしょうに
でも方法はあるんです
やり方は 私のやり方でそんなもんで
ですからお願いしますからという風に言えば
もしアドバイスをできなかった
断った場合は 言われたことは無責任な批判として無視するんです
無責任に喋ってるだけで
もうもうバカな人ぐらいだともう帰ればいいんです
だからそんなに気にすることはないんですよ
言われたっても その場合は
最大の問題は 自分の心に生まれた悩み
悔しさ 怒りであることを明確にする
これから大事なセクションです
失敗は関係ないんだけど
世の中では失敗と判断したところで
心の中から生まれてくる
この悔しい落ち込んじゃう
それって怒りなんですね
それははっきりとこの心の中から
ギャーギャーギャーギャーぎゅうぎゅうと湧いてくるんだから
嫌な気持ちがね それをはっきりしなくちゃいけないんです
今すっごく嫌な気分になっているんだと
今はもう自殺したい気分でいるんだと
その気分そのものをはっきりするんです
その感情を放っておくと
失敗はさらに悪化して自己破壊まで進むので危険であることを理解する
この感情を置く置いとくものじゃない
これ危ないんだと この落ち込みなどがね
もうずっと湧いてきますからね
危ないと 失敗どうでもいいんです
この感情が危ないんだと ７
心の落ち込みなどの感情は自分自身ではなく
心から湧き出た汚いとしてイメージする
私が落ち込んだ 私が落ち込んだではないんです
それで失敗します この体の中で薄いが湧いてくるんだよ
私は関係ないんだと 自分とは
あの落ち込み 怒り 憎しみ
悔しい気持ち これは汚い
でんでん湧いてくるんだよと思ったら
なんか自分と違うものとわかるんですよ
8 その汚いが体から出ていくまで
自分の感情 心の状態を冷静に観察する
それでパッと湧き上がった汚いだから
それから出ていくまでじーっと感情を見ているんです
見てると面白くなるんですよ
すごい嫌な気分になったんですけど
あれ どんどん上がってきた薄いの流れがどんどんどんどん減っていって
消えていくんです すごい気持ち楽になるんです
嫌だ 嫌だ 嫌だではないんです
薄いが湧いてきたとイメージして
それから水だからね とにかくこれは出ていくんですね
出ていくまでじっと観察すればいいんです
落ち着いてから失敗について観察する
それ気持ちよくなったところで
ではどんな失敗したんでしょうかね
この人は と それから自分の失敗を観察すればいいんです
その時はすごく気持ちよくなってます
失敗はどれぐらい大きいか
恥ずかしいかではなく
観察するというのはどのように処理するのかということです
だから失敗を観察しなさいと言っても
また違うんです 失敗を観察するんじゃなくて
これってどう処理すればいいでしょうかなと
大変なことになったんだけど
という処理が大事なんです
10で終わりたいんですからね
失敗した 嫌だではなく
失敗した どうすれば良いのかです
だからどうすればということだけなんです
観察するときに必要なポイントは
そうすると ああ こうしましょうということになるんですよ
だからまず嫌な気持ちを消えるまでじっといて
終わったところで失敗したんだから
ではどうしようかと どうしようっていうところに観察を入れるんです
終わると思います